my hope today was to talk about a
hypothesis a hypothesis about
myocarditis and why it is being
triggered by mrna vaccines of the type
we have seen i'm not going to present
this
as factual i do not know that this is
true
but what i do know
is
that an understanding of
a bit of biology and understanding of
what viruses are about the predicament
that viruses put multicellular creatures
like us in
and the way that our ancestors have
evolutionarily learned to fend off
viruses suggests a hazard about this
new and amazing but until now untested
technology
when introduced into the human body
so that's my hope and i think the thing
to do here is you're going to play
student and i don't mean student in the
sense that most people are familiar with
it i mean it in the sense that
we
scientists become each other's students
at the point that we have something to
discuss where uh where we don't know
right we are the students of
of those who have seen something we have
not yet seen so you're going to play
that role on behalf of the
the audience which means
explicitly the expectation is that i
interrupt you when uh you say something
that i don't find clear or that i
uh maybe disagree with yeah maybe
disagree with and maybe i learned
something because you forced me to see
something about what i'm saying that i
didn't see when i went through it myself
um something like that okay and you know
of course the
lovely thing is that this is exactly how
we behaved in a classroom and we had a
group of
you know if we taught together something
like 50 students but we would also be
each other students in that context and
certainly we have different areas of
specialty and it all works out pretty
well because really what you always want
when you're trying to understand
something is somebody who understands
why you don't get something yet to ask
the question that causes it to be
explained in a way that you do get
and potentially model
what other people
may or may not already know
right that's so the difference between
say the dinner table
and a classroom is that the classroom is
going to be a representative sample of
at least you know some
of something of some larger group
and uh you will hear from people you
know if you hear from a few people that
isn't making any sense to me there's a
decent chance that either there's a
there's a there's a lack of
understanding in the population that you
didn't know was there was a way that
you're communicating it that um that is
is in someone in in some number of
people's blind spots so let's you know
let's try this this is this is tougher
than either a dining room table or you
know dinner table or a classroom because
the audience really is a lot it's all of
you
who we can't hear we can't hear and we
don't know in detail so we can't even
guess what is in his uncle but we hear a
little bit and in fact we'll end maybe
today with a with a one of so many
lovely notes that we got um in these
last couple of weeks from people um but
uh
but we can't hear in real time so anyway
and i would just say that there are
many many different
moves that the student in this case is
entitled to avail themselves of
including you know here's a question i
don't think the
i don't think the audience will know
x piece i think i know it but i'm going
to ask you the question anyway to get
you to spell it out so
anyway the yeah you you have tools
i don't know what you just did was
rhetorical if you're about to now ask me
something no okay that was rhetorical
that was just pointing out that i am not
necessary in explaining this to you i am
really using you as a surrogate for
people most of whom aren't biologists
and so anyway i'm going to err in the
direction of being overly clear
hopefully
all right so
here's the predicament
viruses i believe i'm going to
oversimplify everything because that's
what we do
in science especially anything in the
area of complex systems the fact is we
do not fully understand biology we're a
long way away so what we do when we
discuss biology
is we
describe a cartoonish version of the
reality and hopefully our cartoon is
simplified but not incorrect right we
described an overly simple version of
the reality and hopefully if you were to
expand it to the full level of
complexity it wouldn't contradict what
you say that's the objective
so i'm going to describe enough about
viruses and enough about the immune
system for you to see a picture that i
think i increasingly see
clearly right that may explain why
myocarditis is a downstream effect of
rna vaccinations
or at least some of them and
in so saying i do not mean that this is
the only reason right we have different
kinds of hypotheses you've got mutually
exclusive hypotheses where if this is
causing it then that isn't causing it
but in this case i'm just simply saying
here is one mechanism that i believe is
likely to create a link between these
things and there may be others okay let
me um ask you right up off the bat then
you are see you are going to propose a
hypothesis uh that posits an explanation
for why myocarditis is downstream of
these mrna
vaccinations of course we now know that
myocarditis is one of the sometimes
effects of
go of cyroscopy to infection of the
actual disease covid uh is this a
separate hypothesis from that uh and if
so do you for it does does this explain
that separately and if so do you have a
separate explanation for why you think
uh cyroscov2 may also be
causing myocarditis so i will so
myocarditis my understanding of it and
i'm not a heart specialist by any means
my understanding of it is that it is
effectively
inflammation of the heart muscle and
inflammation can be downstream of
various other processes now my guess and
i do not know but my guess
is that the inflammation caused by
covid is different in origin than the
inflammation caused by
the
by the mrna vaccines and i believe i
have learned this by listening to dr
mccullough who is a cardiac specialist
and i should also point out
as i was
realizing as i was formulating
my hypothesis for what's going on here i
shared it with several people
and uh
one of those people
alexandros morenos said i believe i have
heard that hypothesis elsewhere and he
in fact pointed me to a place where dr
mccullough appears to um to spell it out
and i also now know that our friend
jonathan cui who some of you will know
from his uh lab leak series early
in the pandemic called jc on a bike
journal club on a bike
that he also has advanced the version of
this hypothesis so i don't claim it to
be unique i do think i arrived at it
independently
but
in any case here here's the basics
we multicellular creatures have a
problem with pathogens and pathogens
come in different flavors right you've
got things like fungi
a comparatively rare pathogen for us
bacteria a comparatively common pathogen
for us and viruses a very common
pathogen now you want to compare in your
mind the difference between bacteria and
viral
infections
bacteria are living creatures
and as such they have a biology of their
own it is simplified relative to us
eukaryotes
right
because bacteria are smaller and simpler
than we are but nonetheless they are
biological creatures in their own right
viruses
are
an interesting kind of exception they
function biologically but they are
definitionally on in a gray area and the
reason for that is that viruses have
abandoned
the
mechanisms that allow a biological
creature to function now how is it that
they function if they've abandoned those
mechanisms well they borrow those
mechanisms so they are in some sense
analogous to
special forces that you might drop
behind enemy lines that would not carry
a great deal of equipment with them but
would have the
the knowledge of how to utilize
stuff that they find inside of enemy
territory for their own use so instead
of
you know getting tanks and airplanes and
things in behind enemy lines you you
drop something that is full of
information about how to utilize what
they find locally to the same effect and
viruses are effectively this they have
gotten a tremendous advantage by
abandoning their own biology and
commandeering the biology of the
creatures that they infect once they
invade right
and
what this means is that we have a
problem in trying to fight them because
almost everything that viruses do isn't
really them it's our own machinery that
has been commandeered and has now been
turned against us okay can i interject
here please um
just uh just a point of clarification
which i think is not at all central to
your argument but um i believe and i
think i may have missed something but i
believe that you said um pathogens can
come in the form of sort of fungus and
bacteria and viruses and it seems to me
that fungus is a really tiny tiny kind
of human pathogen but there's two large
classes that aren't included in that so
just just in service of sort of
categorizing what kinds of human
pathogens there are there are of course
um single-celled
eukaryotic
pathogens like plasmodium which is the
um the
microbe that causes malaria
um so you know bacteria are
single-celled prokaryotes without
without a new cell nucleus and then
there are single-celled eukaryotes what
used to be called protists i think but
it's sort of a giant giant junk group
you know it doesn't have a single
evolutionary origin and then of course
there are um multicellular organisms
animals like like worms sure right um so
just just to just to have like a
categorization your pathogens come in
all all of these single celled multicell
all of these things um the distinction
really that i think you're trying to
make here is virus versus not virus
right where you know the virus and you
know there are lots of other
functional ways of discriminating
between them but the particular
distinction that you're making
is because a virus has stripped itself
of almost all biological functioning
um it can act as effectively special
forces yep right um it can it can come
in
um and i mean you didn't say this yet
but you've said this to me before it can
come in sort of like the dude with the
backpack and sneak in uh without having
all of you know it doesn't have a tank
and it doesn't have you know all the
stuff that makes it easy for the body in
this case to say ah there it is there it
is it's easy for it to sneak in under
under the wire and and without
um alarming the self-defense okay so i
want to add two things one there's even
a weirder category than virus we now
know this is something that was very
much learned during our lifetimes
um which is that there's also something
that's even more stripped down which is
a prion disease and it's not even really
clear that a prion disease
it's not clear that it's serving its own
interests a prion disease is a
contagious misfolding of proteins right
and so anyway that's very it's very
pathogenic from the point of view of
doing harm spongiform encephalopathy
being you know mad cow disease being a
classic example of this but you know a
virus is at least
creature-like in the sense of we know
what it's trying to accomplish a prion
disease could just be
an error that
echoes right i'm not going to pretend to
know i'm sure there are people who know
better than i do but
nonetheless the the spectrum goes from
things like a worm right which is
similar to us a multicellular uh
creature to single-celled creatures to
non-celled creature-like things viruses
to
folding errors right yeah and all of
these things have have pathological
implications
um but let's take your example of the
special forces guy who parachutes behind
enemy lines let's say he gets a tank he
gets behind enemy lines he sneaks up
behind somebody who's got a tank slips
his throat and takes over the tank right
now you've got a question which is your
own forces are now looking at a tank
that looks like them
that's our tank
but it's it's pointing at us right
so the point is which tanks of ours do
we now shoot at right
and that is the question that viruses
create and so
without going too deeply into the issues
of immunity
the overarching story of immunity for
creatures like us
is something called self
versus non-self recognition
what happens is early in development
there is a process in which your immune
system which in principle is capable of
responding to effectively any
biological molecule that immune system
is asked a question before you encounter
the outside world and the question is
which things can you currently see now
if during that period you know in utero
you see molecules that are biological
well then okay those are yours right
they almost have to be right because
you're insulated from the outside world
and so well they're yours they're moms
well but that's just the thing even that
the placenta is a
absolutely remarkable organ that does
not get enough attention right the way
in which it allows mother and baby's
systems to interact without exchanging
very much
above a certain size is miraculous
but the point is the self non self
recognition system is programmed during
development to recognize all of the
stuff that you yourself produce and then
to go on for the rest of your life and
ignore it right
then once you build a system that
recognizes all of the molecules you
produce and ignores them now it can do
something else which is now anytime it
sees anything that isn't on the ignore
list it can assume it's a pathogen right
that means that you don't need to have
seen a particular pathogen before in
order to know to fight it right right so
it's a simple rubric that can be gamed
that can be gamed and also has certain
failure modes like allergy
right so if pollen gets into your lungs
well your immune system won't recognize
it as self but it's not a pathogen and
so fighting it can be worse than
ignoring it but you don't know that it's
actually should be on the ignore list
and
there's lots of interesting stuff about
the
the ige system ig is the abbreviation
for antibodies which are the most famous
component of the system which we know
which has also allowed our minds to be
gamed but
nonetheless ige
is one of the subsets of antibodies that
appears to be particularly prone to
create allergic reactions and it's
probably particularly prone to create
allergic reactions because it's not busy
doing the things that it would normally
do like fight worms which we don't have
a problem with in the first place
because we have such a sterile landscape
that we've created for our bodies and
our environments right so you've got
some part of your immune system that's
twiddling its thumbs and it overreacts
to you know yeah it's it's the bank's
grasp and it's grasp right i could just
sit down
just relax we got this it's grasp on but
okay so
you've got a system and it functions
basically by
ignoring everything that you make and
therefore
feeling entitled to react to anything
that you don't make
now again remember what viruses are
viruses are these um
they are like
particles with a creature creature-like
objective but no creature like bits
right it's just like an envelope with
creature-like objective written on the
letter inside
and that letter if it gets into your
cells instructs the cells to do what the
virus if it were a creature would do for
itself right make more viruses
so here's the here's the thing
when viruses get into us wherever that
happens if they're respiratory viruses
it will typically be in the surface of
the lungs for example um you know we get
other kinds of viruses it'll be in other
tissues but the virus gets in if it
manages to get into a cell enough that
it's message can trigger the cell to
start doing the virus is bidding rather
than the creatures bidding then that
cell
becomes effectively a factory
that is dedicated to the viruses
interests
now
the body has to now look at this the
same way you would look at a tank that
had been commandeered by enemy forces
that had parachuted over your border and
grabbed a tank right it has to say aha i
used to think that was self but i gotta
that one drives different right that one
drives on the left side of the road not
the right side of the road or something
i got to shoot at that one as if it's
the enemy because it actually is
even though it also has the tags that
say self right it has the tags that say
self but it has
indicators that it is not anymore itself
and so
the basic punch line here
is that
when
our body
sees a cell
that
looks like us
but does something extra in other words
it puts out messages that look like
non-self
it concludes
that is a virally infected cell and the
right thing to do is then to kill it
because a virally infected cell is not
going to become unvirally infected so
there's no trade-off like how much is
that cell worth to me
uh you know dead versus alive the point
is once it's been commandeered even
though losing a cell is not a good thing
it's better than that cell continuing to
do the enemies bidding
so the immune system targets cells and
in fact the cells themselves have an
interest in being targeted because they
only pass on their genes if the creature
survives and the creature survives
better if it's not infected so the cell
effectively would volunteer for death
um okay
but the basic point is what does a
virally infected cell look like it looks
like a weird hybrid between self and
non-self right it has
self markers because it's a self cell
and it has foreign markers because
its internal machinery has been
commandeered and it's now making
proteins that the body has never seen
before etc etc
okay
so
now what happens if you
do what these mrna vaccines do right if
you just assume that they function as
the brochure tells you that they should
these vaccines
contain a message they are viral like in
this way they contain a message without
biological structure around it and it is
encoded
or it is uh it is it's even more
stripped down than the virus itself yeah
it is a single message in this case
these are cartoonishly simple vaccines
in the sense that they produce one
antigen the spike protein
and that spike protein is wrapped in
lipid nanoparticles now why is it lipid
nanoparticles it's lipid nanoparticles
because light dissolves like and by
surrounding these things in lipids they
are protected from the parts of the uh
human system that would disassemble
the mrnas is i'm not sure how to dance
that but um uh that are in the intra
intercellular space would
immediately tear apart the mrna if it
weren't protected right so by putting it
in this envelope they make it invisible
to a system that would otherwise attack
it as foreign
and they also cause it to have an
affinity for human cells those human
cells all cells are covered in this
lipid envelope and so because light
dissolves like the lipid
and this is one of these places where
the story retail isn't exactly right the
lipids being non-polar are not actually
attracted to each other but they're
driven together by all the polar stuff
sticking to itself
so well on the lipids on the cells
actually this phospholipid bilayer which
has you know things sticking inside
which
yeah anyway so
the point is the lipid coat the lipid
nanoparticle coat causes the mrna
to get taken up by cells and those cells
because of the way the cells are
constructed so the con cells are
constructed they have a nucleus that has
their normal human cells normal human
cells they have a nucleus with a
dna genome in it
certain
mrnas are produced
from genes that the cell wants to
transcribe
and
they're produced from genes that the
cell wants to transcribe those mrna
messages move from inside the nucleus
into the cytoplasm and in the cytoplasm
you have ribosomes that automatically
translate mrnas that they encounter so
the whole clever thing about these
vaccines and it is truly clever is if
you put an mrna message into the
cytoplasm of a cell the cell
automatically transcribes it because the
cell is built to do that because it
wouldn't encounter mrnas in its
cytoplasm other than in the case of
maybe being infected it's the factory
behind enemy lines uh if you know if the
virus is the enemy and the virus is
dropping in you're like okay can we get
can we get
self to make
things that look like used to trigger
the immune system to say aha now i know
and once informed i will not forget
right okay so you get cells they pick up
the mrna from the vaccine they start
producing spike protein now the design
of these vaccines right the spike
protein has been modified
the hope of that modification which
failed actually so it doesn't completely
do this but presumably it is it does it
somewhat modified from the so-called
wild type sorry scoby2 right yeah so
it's been modified in a couple ways the
uh
it's got a hinged piece that's been
locked open
in order to expose
a piece of the antigen to the immune
system that would otherwise be so the
because the virus is a very sneaky
evolved creature it's covered in sugars
basically that shield what would
ordinarily trigger the immune system
from seeing the spike protein so they've
locked it open so the immune system sees
it but anyway the point is they put in
this anchor domain
to get these spike proteins to stick out
of the surface of the cells the hope
being that the immune system will see
these antigens sticking off the surface
of the cells we'll learn what they look
like and you will magically become
immune to the pathogen when it shows up
with very similar antigens on its
surface immunomagically immunomagically
well well said okay here's the problem
a cell
that is
displaying the spike protein on its
surface
will
look in all probability to the immune
system like an indication that that cell
has been virally infected because that
cell is now displaying a mixture of self
and non-self proteins
and the immune system has no model for
this
because the only time that that would
likely take place under natural
circumstance is viral infection the
right response to a cell that is doing
that is to kill it because as much as
that cell is useful it has been lost
right if your enemy has captured a tank
of yours you're better off even though
that was your tank
you're better off destroying it because
at the moment it's working for the enemy
and not you
so the immune system seeing cells that
have taken up the lipid nanoparticles
and transcribed the message inside the
right response for the immune system is
that is a virally infected cell and it
has to go
right now this is the wrong thing if you
could
tell the body what was really going on
what you would want to say is look stand
down the immune system
because that cell that looks like it has
been permanently compromised has only
been temporarily compromised
those mrna
messages will eventually be lost and the
cell will go back to doing its own
bidding which is not something that
happens in a virally infected cell
so
the immune system reacts it overreacts
right and it destroys these cells now
the problem is and this this is where
this whole set of questions that we've
been dealing with over the course of
covid interacts with all the weird stuff
i did as a graduate student surrounding
telomeres and
cancer and
tumors
the heart
is a weird tissue
now the reason that the heart is a weird
tissue
is that the heart does not have
normal repair capacity almost all of
your tissues have the capacity to
replace dead cells with new cells and to
keep functioning it always comes at a
cost because you're always borrowing
from the future capacity to repair that
tissue and maintain it so every time you
destroy some tissue and have to replace
it you're effectively accelerating your
aging
but the heart is super special it's one
of a small number of tissues it doesn't
do that trick and what that means is
that when you destroy a cell in the
heart it doesn't get replaced by a
similar cell right
this is maybe too far afield but it
strikes me that the heart not having
repair capacity
is
four analogous reasons to
salmon being symbol paris
that it is about
the chances
of
surviving repair or in the case of
salmon the chances of surviving another
trip back out to the ocean and years and
another move back into the into the
fresh water where you came from and
having another reproductive opportunity
um the chances in both of those cases
are so low
that in the case of the heart the repair
capacity has been dialed all the way
down um and in the case of salmon
they've become a you know breed once
then die
species well interesting i think there's
an analogy i think it is actually
different but if i can it's a different
analogy yeah if i can rephrase what
you've said there's a point at which
your likelihood of making it to a second
reproductive event is so low if you're a
salmon if you're a salmon or really if
you're anything there's a point at which
if you are at reproduction
your chances of getting back to
reproduction are so low that you ought
to invest everything in that
reproductive event that you've reached
and therefore there's a shift where it's
like anything you anything you hold back
is wasted in all probability so you
might as well invest it all here that is
to say any tissue that you can turn into
more eggs or more sperm is better spent
now because it's very unlikely to get
back to this very difficult place yeah
specifically pacific samuel we're
talking about yeah
right and so anyway um yeah there's a
whole interesting discussion here i have
hypothesized that actually bears may be
the difference it could also be the
sharpness of the western mountains but
the point is the the
stakes are very different in the west
uh part of north america than the east
in a way that has caused
all but one of our western
salmon to go
seml paris
yeah
okay
so back to the heart why is the heart a
different case than the salmon case yeah
the hypothesis i put forward in my paper
with debbie seasick in i guess it was
published in 2002 finally that's right
the hypothesis that we put forward was
the reason that the heart lacks this
capacity
is that in order to have the capacity to
do cellular repair
you run the risk of creating what we
call a prototumor a prototumor is a
growth of cells if a cell becomes
unregulated oh yes and it produces a
bunch of you know if a cell becomes deaf
to the messages that say stop dividing
then it will just simply divide
and if a cell does that in the heart it
could create a prototumor let's imagine
something the size of a p
well a growth the size of a pea if it
happens in your liver you're never going
to know about it if it happens on your
skin it will be a mole if it happens in
your heart it could block an artery and
kill you right so the point is the
danger of a prototumor is so high and
again this is a hypothesis i don't know
if it's true and as far as i know it's
never been tested but the danger of a
growth of cells out of place in the
heart is so large that
the system
has had repair turned all the way down
so that there is no hazard of that and
as a result the heart is this
absolute marvel of design
or as if design
where it goes for
85 100 years
effectively
flawlessly without the capacity for
repair and there will be people saying
there is capacity prepared yeah there
may be a tiny bit in general though
instead of repair what you get is the
capacity to scar right and scar
is basically like
biology's speckle
right it's not
the thing that is being replaced it's
something that's good enough
um
yeah and so in any case
to make a long story shorter here
you've got
an mrna message which causes cells to
transcribe or to translate a protein
that is not self
which almost cannot help but be read by
the immune system as an indication that
those cells have been virally infected
which they haven't been
but the immune system doesn't know about
mrna vaccines and so it will assume
that the category that explains this
anomaly is infected cell and it will do
what the right thing to do is which is
to destroy that cell when in fact the
right thing to do here is to leave that
cell alone let the mrna messages burn
themselves out and let the cell go back
to its job
because damaging the heart is not a good
idea right damaging the heart is not a
good idea
i think one of the pieces i see missing
yet is um
obviously it was hoped it was expected
we were told that
the mrna vaccines would stay basically
local to the spot of injection
and it is well documented at this point
that that has not happened
is the idea
that
they spread and maybe they are
predictable maybe maybe we could make
predictions with regard to you know
whether or not
the proper aspiration happened you know
whether or not it was left or right arm
you know a number of these things have
been proposed um where it will spread to
or
is the prediction that that um
the
the
vaccine is going to be spreading
throughout the body uh much to the
chagrin of those who develop the
vaccines
and
that doesn't have necessarily widespread
horrible effects except when it ends up
in the heart it's not that it is
specifically going to the heart it's
that it's ending up everywhere which it
never was intended to do and when it
ends up at the heart that's going to
have particularly bad effects yeah it's
it's an
i if the hypothesis is correct it is a
close analogy for what i found to be
likely with respect to drug toxicity
back in the days of my telomere work
which is right we see the heart damage
for a couple of reasons one because the
heart is very bad at self-repair so
damage shows up in a meaningful way
the same amount of damage in most other
tissues would never bother us right
you'd get better and you wouldn't know
that you'd lost some future capacity for
repair
and b
the failure of the heart is utterly
unambiguous right so let's say that the
vaccine
robs you of a bunch of liver capacity
well good news you were born with excess
liver capacity and so the point is
probably you don't die of liver failure
you die of something else so probably
you got away with it right if it's the
heart
well you probably didn't get away with
it you've borrowed from something
important right heart failure is one of
the major so you've got basically two
important uh biotic ways to die for a
well-fed well-protected creature one of
them has to do with uh
growth of tissues that shouldn't grow
basically tumors and cancers and the
other has to do with the failure of
organs that are necessary
and heart being primary among the organs
that are likely to fail and kill you and
the point is when this happens in
somebody young
it's conspicuous because it doesn't
happen in somebody young under ordinary
circumstances so when somebody drops
dead on the football pitch
that
catches our attention now it's not that
that never happens under normal
circumstances but there's a question
about is it happening more
than we're used to and is there a reason
for that and
basic
point here is that you've got
a mechanism of action the the expected
mechanism of action the desired
mechanism of action
is for this message to be taken up by
cells and and translated into protein
that is likely to trigger
the biological phenomenon of non-self
recognition and the de facto conclusion
of the immune system this is an infected
cell and it needs to be killed
when that happens in the heart it is
both
worse for you because your heart's not
good at dealing with it and more
conspicuous to medical science because
somebody who shouldn't have had a heart
attack just did right
and that that is resulting in this now
you raise an interesting point about
the
potential asymmetry
and this is this is one of the little
corollary hypotheses here which is that
um
if this is true if this is the mechanism
or one of the mechanisms that is causing
serious myocarditis to come to people
who have
been vaccinated with these
mrna vaccines
there's a question about whether or not
what is it that causes it to be taken up
by the heart right the thing that is
lacking in these vaccines right if these
vaccines were really to be
brilliant enough to be
wielded in this way they might have a
targeting mechanism that would cause
them to be taken up only by tissues that
you could afford
to suffer this fate right and not to be
taken up by tissues that you very
definitely wanted to protect from it
like the heart and they don't have that
they've got no targeting mechanism in
that all in them at all so what they are
do what happens is you have a um an
arbitrary
uptake right it's not
random because some cells are more prone
to take up the mrna uh they have lipid
nanoparticles than others and the heart
as i understand it is prone to take them
up so if they flow to the heart first if
they escape the
the arm
and they flow to the heart
then that's a very likely place for them
to be taken up and then what you'll end
up with is dead tissue in the heart that
then hopefully scars over and hopefully
you close to get away with it but you're
losing capacity from your heart for life
um
but
there's all kinds of questions if this
is actually true and again it's just a
hypothesis but if it's actually true
then it raises all kinds of questions
about what
how might we have vaccinated people that
would reduce this effect right so for
example
should you be getting this one in the
arm would you be better off getting this
shot in the ass right it's possible that
the circulatory pattern would be less
devastating because the stuff would get
taken up before it gets to your heart
now i don't know enough about
circulation to say maybe it would make
things worse if they gave it to you in
the butt cheek but
um
but that's one possibility another
possibility is that there's a symmetry
in the circulatory system right heart
attacks cause left arm
pain and so there's a question
um we don't know because we didn't get
this vaccine but it's possible that they
sit you down they say which arm would
you like this in and it's possible that
that shouldn't be your choice that they
should give it to you in the arm that
protects your heart better right so
anyway there are all kinds of questions
you could ask here
and
because what we've been fed is oh these
things are safe we can't you know
john campbell did a marvelous uh
exploration of the question of
aspiration
right it's possible that you know it's
possible these vaccines are simply not
safe enough to do this but they could be
rendered a lot safer than they are by
things like aspiration technique by
tissue in which they are injected
and that we aren't asking those
questions because instead we've been fed
a fairy tale about safety right
myocarditis
the fact that only some people suffer
post-facts is it due to random
distribution of
spike protein
bad luck or
might some people be more susceptible to
genetic due to genetics or some tolerate
it better and never notice the weaker
course of illness ah sweet yeah we can
do this yeah so yeah
it's written sort of telegraphically so
i was just trying to translate it as i
was reading it
many things are true one there is liable
to be a roll of the dice thing right
like you've got an actual
volume of liquid with actual stuff in it
and it's going to circulate in some
chaotic way and to the extent that
particular uh lipid nanoparticle coated
pieces of rna um bump into the walls in
the heart and then get absorbed whereas
others were you know three millimeters
away from the heart as they went through
tissues downstream yep all of that
chaotic flow stuff is going to mean that
some people are going to get a huge dose
in the heart some people are going to
get a very low dose in the heart and the
aspiration thing that john campbell
uh surfaced may have everything to say
about this because the point is maybe
everybody who gets a huge dose in the
heart are people
where the
needle actually hit a circulatory vessel
rather than the interstitial
space
there might be something about the
variation between batches although i
don't know if we know anything about
what the variation between batches
vaccine batches
uh actually means in terms of how it
manifests in the body yeah if it's even
a thing and
right so it's tough to face down
um there could be
heritable differences my guess is it's
very small yeah me too if it's a
component at all
um i think i mean because because it's
your heart right it could be because
because you simply there's simply no
backup
and uh if it gets there it's going to be
a problem for you i was thinking
actually when we were talking in the
first hour
um you know what else
why now obviously you you and debbie
spent a long time thinking about this
for you know many years but you know
what else might be like the heart and
therefore you would predict to have
really low repair capacity and the one
thing i came up with and it's not
perfect because we got two of them
is the loop of henle in the kidney not
kidney tissue writ large but
specifically the mammalian synapomorphy
the the unique character of mammalian
kidneys that allows for
basically the recovery of more water and
the excretion of of liquid waste through
that thing that's called the loop of
henle which is so thin
that you know a problem there could
could similarly take one of your kidneys
offline
yeah essentially right away you've got
so many actual loops of henle right i
mean these are
tiny structures and you have presumably
millions of them
no
it's a
i'm
i hope i'm not wrong here but you know
there's lots of little things off of it
but like in the main loop
uh
i'm gonna stay out of it because i don't
know okay um
yeah i think you got two basically well
um but but maybe i'm wrong about that
let's see you've got other tissues that
behave in a weird way
um and i would argue
what i argued in the paper back in
the late 90s early 2000s was
um
that certain tissues have reasons not to
have high repair capacity and that all
of them are low
cancer risk
and high
wearing out potential
basically that's the pattern that any
tissue in which you've got
high repair capacity has a substantial
risk of tumor growth and a substantial
capacity to repair damage but that
things like the eye
the eye has a low capacity for repair
and tends to wear out
cartilage has very little capacity for
repair
and tends to wear out and you don't get
cartilage cancer
and you don't get eye cancer but you get
like optic nerve cancer there's nervous
tissue cancer
there's blood vessel cancer but the eye
itself doesn't tend to get cancer right
right yeah right and the heart doesn't
tend to get cancer right pericardium the
membrane around the heart does when
people get cancers right in that
neighborhood that tends to be the
pericardium but anyway it's a general
general that's interesting because of
course myocarditis and pericarditis are
the two or the two kinds of inflammation
that are really happening here and all
the discussion that we had earlier was
about myocarditis not pericarditis which
is an inflammation of the pericardium
which is the membrane around the heart
well actually we might form some
pericardial cavity i forgot to say in
our main podcast which is that
effectively the hypothesis
uh that i put forward
is a hypothesis of
temporary
autoimmunity
right yes
so we've got
autoimmunity is the immune system
mistaking self
for hostile and attacking self
my argument is
the mrna in heart tissue
is likely to trigger the immune system
to attack the heart but the
mrna transcripts that cause the
production of the spike protein are
presumably transient
and so the point is if the if the immune
system were to hold back and not attack
these cells the cells would go back to
being normal
and so the point is it is a temporary
autoimmunity that causes the permanent
destruction of cells in the heart
that then results in the heart being
effectively enfeebled damaged
um
so anyway i wish i'd said that in the
main podcast but
here's what it is that's what it is
indeed um
and then this i mean there's
more categories than this but these this
does seem like a good group of three is
it luck
is it genetics is it terrible um or do
some tolerate it better and never notice
the weaker course of illness ah so this
is a biggie yeah
um if the hypothesis is correct one of
the things that it predicts is that
there will be a ton of subclinical
myocarditis that will never be described
yeah and what that means the way we will
see it manifest is shortened life spans
right a large fraction of people
ultimately die from heart failure
and that those deaths will happen
earlier than they would otherwise have
happened because their heart has
effectively expended what compare repair
capacity it has early in life and been
caused to be less capable
now this of course fits
with
the
observation which i believe is likely to
be robust that we have an unusual number
of people dying
during
sporting events and the basic point is
that athletes are being pushed to a
limit that most people are not regularly
pushed to and that the point is a heart
that can function below that threshold
will suddenly fail when stressed to a
point because it has lost
some of its heart capacity
to vaccines that trigger this temporary
autoimmunity yeah and there's something
new out which i haven't tracked yet
about catecholamines and you know sort
of having an environment in which
adrenaline and noradrenaline and
dopamine i think is the third
catecholamine
um being at elevated levels may make uh
heart failure and the already
compromised heart more likely the
myocarditis in an already compromised
heart more likely
i'm but i can't but i can't track it
more than that yet yeah i have
it's on my list of places to delve but i
haven't i haven't delved into that
result yet can i have myocarditis
without symptoms will it go away
i got tinnitus three days after the
booster since i have no recourse should
i cheat on my taxes since the government
cheated me
wow yeah
you shouldn't not cheat on your taxes
you shouldn't but uh they really are not
holding up there into the bargain are
they nope they are not they are not uh
can you have myocarditis without
symptoms yeah i mean i think this is the
subclinical um stuff that you were
referring to and uh for sure there will
be people who have damage and who
are never aware that they have damage
and may never become aware they have
damage or may become aware later um oh
it looks like you have some past damage
your doctor tells you 20 years later and
you say no i really don't ah well
could have been that injection yep
uh anything else to say here will it go
away um it does it seems to pass but um
but it doesn't it's it leaves scarring
well it will reduce the capacity of your
heart presumably for life now there no i
want to take that back yeah i don't know
that's true no i believe it's true okay
but let's put it to you this way i think
what i've learned from peter mccullough
is
that you really have two kinds of
myocarditis you've got an inflammation
that goes away but
is not the result of cellular
destruction
that the myocarditis that is the result
of cellular destruction will permanently
reduce the capacity of your heart which
depending upon what you do you know if
you're an elite athlete probably you
won't be an elite athlete after that
happens
and mccullough's argument is the kind of
myocarditis that does not involve
cellular destruction is the kind that
sars cov2 causes
but that the kind of myocarditis uh that
does cause cellular destruction is
brought on by presumably among other
things uh the mrna vaccines is that is
that the right categorization i think so
i don't want to represent his position
because i've got it wrong i've got it
wrong
but yes i believe that is his argument
competing hypothesis
blood goes to the heart twice before
going on to liver kidneys gonads signs
of ovarian damage exist nobody's
studying it well
i i like it and there is something to
the idea of blood goes to the heart
twice but it goes on two different sides
and so we ought to be able
to sort
we ought to be able to look at the
damage and actually read this pattern
into it
yeah i don't i don't
i don't buy this precisely because we
have a four chambered heart and um
there's a little
um bit of slosh but for the most part um
the four chambered heart keeps the
pulmonary and the systemic circuitry
completely separate
and so the you know the cardiac muscle
which is doing the pumping
has within it these chambers these two
atrium two ventricles
each of which gets
um you know half
is full of blood at any given time but
half of it just came back from the lungs
and half of it just came back from the
body
and never the twin shall meet that's you
know that's that's what fortunate heart
means a three-chambered heart there's a
lot of mixing uh to a two-chambered
heart as well um but yeah we and and
birds and crocodilians if memory serves
with our distinctly uh separate
pulmonary and systemic systems uh don't
have the mixing so i don't understand
what that falsifies
well what what is it going to a spot
twice if it's not if if blood isn't
going to any spot twice it's going to
like yeah you've got a vessel right
right and half of it is here and half of
it is here uh why would it why
why would it
like i i don't understand because that's
two chances so i first of all i'm not
compelled that i understand the
circulation well enough to know that it
would have been there first but it gets
two chances to lodge in the heart
somewhere
right
i guess i guess so it comes back through
some part of the heart and the eye in
the idea
oh
maybe i mean the thing is you ought to
be able to
a i would love to know
uh whether or not there is an asymmetry
so i thought it was about a double like
a double
dose in a particular place but no the
okay yeah somewhere in the heart
yeah
yep
all right well that's an interesting
question yep brett according to the
hypothesis you just laid out why is
myocarditis occurring more frequently in
men
well
um it might in part be the catecholamine
connection could be let's put it to you
this way
there is an asymmetry between male and
female that is
pretty much written into the universe
interestingly it re-evolves with
multiple instances of male and female
that causes males to be
stronger and more fragile
and so men live shorter lives are
stronger at their peak
and this has to do with the game theory
surrounding sexual reproduction
and so
it is quite likely that one of the
advantages that men have in sport
has to do with
them being built for
extreme performance in something like
let's say warfare
right and that that extreme performance
is part of a trade-off and that it
borrows from longevity and
things like that and that basically
you know
[Music]
that the heart is more capable and more
fragile in men by design
yep
which doesn't have anything to do with
the hypothesis but it doesn't need to
like you know hypothesis to um
explain to to propose an explanation for
uh the myocarditis that that sometimes
follows mrna vaccination is not expected
to nor should it be expected to explain
all of the variation in myocarditis
right and in fact um you know
again the subclinical manifestation is
gonna
we don't actually know that this is more
common in males what we know is that
it's diagnosed more frequently and
therefore it may be that females tend to
have subclinical cases because
of differences in heart design etc
[Music]